this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking another look at the
weapons from respawn shooter Apex
Legends this is looking pretty
conventional for this style of game
proportions wise it's pretty close to
the uh fostech origin 12 which we are
lucky enough now to have an example of
let us know what other games or guns
you'd like to see Jonathan breakdown and
make sure to subscribe for more of this
kind of content on the channel including
Loadout which takes an in-depth look at
the most iconic firearms in gaming right
let's take a look at the weapons from
Apex Legends
right first impression was very very
bulky like you need massive hands just
to wrap your hand around the pistol grip
bolt handle looks quite conventional
except that it doesn't seem to lock into
anything uh I mean maybe this if this
even works like a conventional firearm
maybe that it has lugs somewhere that
just lock in and you don't need the
handle to be handled doesn't necessarily
have to come to rest in this position it
could stay in that position but it goes
against a little bit tradition in terms
of bolt action rifles but this is no
traditional bolt action rifle because
I've already seen some sort of weird rip
cord Arrangement that seems to spin up
something and make it Glow and increase
the damage of the shot so we're well
beyond my expertise here into the Realms
of Science Fiction I'm not sure about
the little winged creature he looks
quite cute not usually a feature of a
firearm but I think that's probably
incidental
thank you
okay what having seen seen some gameplay
now I think actually this is a ballpark
with them with the magazine located
behind the grip and then there's
effectively uh it's not quite a magazine
it's more like a charging port in front
of the trigger that you're connecting to
charging up for the additional shot and
then just ripping out the cable private
like you might do if you you know you're
in a hurry and you need to get your
phone off charge so not really that
conventional the bolt action is
conventional the high damage low rate of
fire typical first person shooter stuff
and the general silhouette of the weapon
is is pretty straightforward but there's
more to it than meets the eye
okay quite a striking looking firearm if
it is a firearm I think it is magazine
bed recoil operated or some other
conventional system in fact it even has
what looks like a a fairly conventional
laser slash light module attached in
front of the front of the trigger guard
it's very anime it looks actually like
that might the rear portion might deploy
as a shoulder stock making it sort of
compact machine pistol we have a very
rakish angle for the magazine not
optimal for feed by any means and it
carries the rounds to a place where in a
conventional arrangement with a
reciprocating bolt or slide they can't
get picked up and fed into the chamber
carrying your your cartridges straight
to the back of the gun isn't a winning
idea but it makes for a very striking
looking firearm with a sort of thumb
hole receiver frame I do like the look
of this thing I'm intrigued to see how
the the butts stop if indeed there's a
butt stock actually works
foreign
contacts and people online crying out in
horror who uh who are not fans of
reciprocating cocking handles that move
when the weapon fires because they can
get caught on your hand or something or
on a barrier and stop the gun from
working so the usual complaint goes here
we have two of them in the reciprocate
the Scorpion is probably the closest
parallel but but that doesn't have two
barrels this thing has two barrels the
charging handles which stick out to
Fairway do a little dance they alternate
and it's quite it's quite visually
striking and interesting to see happen
but would be a bit of a problem it's
quite a bulky little gun already so
making it extra wide with two charging
handles isn't the best design Choice
firing independently makes a certain
amount of sense from the point of view
of recoil control because if you're
firing both shots at the same time well
that would be like the um the Arsenal
pistol from a few years ago where you're
firing 245 caliber rounds with each shot
and therefore get the recoil at the same
time I guess that's that's the logic to
having it staggered in terms of gameplay
really no reason why it couldn't just be
one barrel or firing at the same rate
out of the same Barrel it's a design
Choice aesthetic Choice really
foreign
we can't seem to get away from it
perhaps we don't want to because it is
very cool uh 30 30 as I'm sure a lot of
you know is a real cartridge type we
don't actually have many 30 30 lever
actions in this collection this is a
model 55 Winchester it looks nothing
like in this game really at all other
than the basic fact that it has a lever
as you can see the bolt is a lot more
conspicuous when it comes back on this
because it has to come back that far to
the hammer and then and you can be
easy to clear the back of the the next
round that's being brought up by this uh
cartridge lifter from the tube magazine
under Barrel so it has to come out that
far the bolt on the gain gun doesn't
seem to come out very far at all from
what I've seen this isn't just a name
this is an attempt to design a
futuristic sci-fi type lever action that
still fires the venerable old probably
centuries old at this point 30 30
cartridge so I quite like it even though
it seems a little bit wild that you'd
still be using something so slow in this
in this kind of setting
thank you
this is a cool fictional design I think
it's a little bit FN SCAR it's a little
bit crisp Vector especially the design
around the magazine housing although in
this case it's a full-size sort of
battle rifle cartridge so that's why
it's so deep with the bacteria it's
hiding a special mechanism but
aesthetically speaking it does look a
bit that way I get sort of a wetter
Workshop sci-fi movie gun vibes from
from the guns in this game especially
this one and maybe a little bit colonial
Marines probably just because of the
green contrasting with the black I'm not
sure about the technical aspects of this
it looks like it could be made to
function the magazine catch is in a
really weird place not not ergonomically
recommended
thank you
looks like some sort of energy or plasma
or energy plasma is energy but uh some
kind of pseudo projectile but it's
really energy type system and with a big
drum power supply slash magazine that
lives in the middle of the gun that you
slap in from the side and gets ejected
outside as well needless to say it
doesn't really relate to anything in the
in reality but it's something new it's a
design I haven't seen before we do get a
ramping up here so we've seen uh
especially machine guns before where the
rate will increase to the point where it
heats up or something here it bursts and
they are ramping up rate of fire each
time you fire something to do with the
energy charge or something again not if
you get changes in rate of fire with a
real conventional firearm something's
wrong with the real conventional firearm
that you're using this makes its own
internal sense in the if it's got more
energy building up somehow then then a
steadily increasing rate of fire might
not make ultimate sense but it makes
sense for the gun
foreign
I wasn't sure if this was a some sort of
assault rifle at first but um realizing
there was no magazine well and then
seeing the arrangement of this and then
how it loads it's obviously a shotgun in
fact we get a sort of loading a single
round through ejection port and then
loading up the rest into the tube below
so quite quite a conventional design
it's it's just really really chunky and
it functions pretty much like a modern
soft loading shotgun semi-automatic
shotgun unusual design at the back uh
looking at the back end we've got a
thumb hole and a sort of Cutlass style
trigger guard bow thing which isn't
great so I mean a thumb hole stock is is
fine for sort of uh sniper rifles or
something not great for something
Dynamic like a shotgun or an automatic
rifle if you need to grab it quickly you
want to get just get your hand around
the grip you don't want to have to get
caught up on that that's a relatively
mind thing but then if you're having to
then get your fingers into the knuckle
bow as well it's a bit busy design wise
and ergonomically not ideal it has this
muzzle brake style muzzle device that
you can see very clearly with the with
the hip fire point of impact reticle it
shows you where your individual
projectiles have struck that it's
actually flattening the spread I haven't
got a duck Bell attachment to show you
but back in the Vietnam War shotguns
would be attached it would have attached
a
triangular shaped flattened
steel muzzle device that would constrain
the pattern so you get a tighter pattern
in this plane same width in this plane
if that makes sense so you're just
you're getting more value for money at
well waist height so you have more
chance of hitting Center Mass and doing
some some serious damage and this is a
science fiction interpretation of that
effect
this gun looking pretty pretty
conventional
um nicely designed but fairly sort of
understandably a light machine gun and a
general short barrel belt bed style you
can tell what it's supposed to be it's
like a like a Sci-Fi lmg um but where
this gets interesting is when when it's
fired so it is fire at chambering and
firing somewhat conventional ammunition
brass cased apparently but those
individual cartridges seem to contain a
charge of energy or maybe the the
propellant is projecting some I don't
know I suspect it's meant to be an
energy weapon that uses energy
cartridges blue muzzle flash and a weird
sort of crackly charge as the rate of
fire ramps up it's one of those machine
guns where you get that steadily
increasing rate of fire which affects
spread and controllability but also
obviously damage if you can control it
you're going to get more damage on
target so there's more going on to this
then just a Mini Me In Space what's not
in space but you know what I mean
this is looking pretty conventional for
this style of game drum fed automatic
shotgun I think I haven't seen it in use
yet but I can I can see a picture it on
my screen proportions wise it's pretty
close to the fostech origin 12 which we
are lucky enough now to have an example
of very sci-fi looking piece of Kit
especially with a short barrel if you
look at this thing in detail though it
is actually very different so every
little detail of this thing is different
to the origin 12. so notably the
separate magazine housing that's on this
uh well this sort of is one on this as
well but it's a different shape
underneath this cool sci-fi exterior is
essentially an AK Style
system this is essentially the AK top
cover this is essentially an akm
receiver underneath and and here's your
trunnion block at the front barely
recognizable but um at the heart of this
thing is an AK whereas that's not the
case here another big difference here
um on the origin as well we have a
cocking handle up front on the left on
the gain gun we've got a clocking handle
similar sort of knocking handle further
back it's on the receiver
um but it doesn't seem to get used after
the Magazine's been inserted it looks
like the weapon is getting pumped does
look like there is a separate pump grip
on the front which this gun doesn't have
because it doesn't need it because it
has a conventional sort of setup there
really wacky bolt on the origins of by
the way but it's essentially an AK
system
foreign
this looks quite a bit like a couple of
the other guns in the game I don't mean
that as a complaint I think having a
consistent design language especially if
the guns are supposed to be made by the
same company it makes a lot of sense you
know in in the universe why would they
why would they look radically different
so the the the lines of the of the guns
the Triangular shape sort of lightening
panels that are sort of machined into
them I think uh if this was a um a real
gun in the real world uh as I find
myself saying the magazine might be a
bit over designed it's got attachments
effectively the the magazine body that
goes into the gun there's no reason why
that shouldn't be the same width and
length and whatever else all the way
down
um we do see things like Magpul style
um base plates to help you pull pull the
magazine out of your kit this seems to
go beyond that though and and it's more
of them it's more to make the magazine
fit the overall design aesthetic
another take on our old friend the fnp90
albeit it's quite different obvious
design cues that carry over are the
what's now a sort of carry handle it's
actually more like a miniature G36
arrangement with a what looks like the
side folding cocking handle of the G36
running inside in the P90 of course it's
part of the magazine housing effectively
but it's it measly makes makes your
brain think P90 the biggest thing that
does of course is this this uh
Arrangement here here though this is a
bit more like the the hero or Hera Arms
AR-15 series of rifles where they have a
foregrip that looks like more like so
like this than P90 and then a a thumb
hole butt stock as well so maybe they're
they're referencing that critically in
terms of P90 comparisons it's
effectively using the ejection Port of
the of the P90 with its internal dust
cover so stuff doesn't go up inside the
the ejection Port but on this it's
purely projecting spent cases here the
similar Arrangement is for inserting a
magazine so it's almost like they looked
at that and went what if that took a
magazine and we had a conventional feed
Arrangement coming into the uh the
bridge back here
foreign
something we can we can easily see
thanks to the all the all the guns in
the game have a visual or visible round
counter something we can easily pick up
on is is the five round burst that's
pretty unusual there are people who
speculate in an educated fashion that
three-round burst is about the worst you
could possibly have two might be enough
to hold the weapon on target for for
both to hit five say might be enough to
be able to bring it back down three tens
so people say and having shot a little
bit myself in that area I tend to agree
first shot's On Target and second and
third are off what I'm getting at is
although it's not very real world five
round burst might just work especially
in something as short and controllable
as a P90 I could be hallucinating but I
thought the magazine which is probably
about that deep had what looked like
sort of miniature rifle cartridges and
more like more like the 5.7 really
pistol class but it's like a miniature
rifle cartridge but the grass that's
flying out of the gun is little Stumpy
nine mil or some something even shorter
than that actually looking at it so I'm
not sure if the case is being ejected
are wrong
foreign
this is this is kind of dressed up with
some sci-fi Aesthetics but at its heart
it's a self-loading pistol fully
automatic pistol with a conventional
reciprocating slide uh it's just got a
an addition an extension to the frame
that allows you to mount a site forward
of the ejection Port this setup is a bit
more reminiscent of an old school
competition pistol with a rail mounted
into the frame arching over the slide to
which you would mount a red dot or even
a telescopic site depending on what
discipline you're shooting so in a way
it's a sort of throwback but it does
look very modern no hint of how it
functions except that there doesn't
appear to be any mechanical lock up it
looks like it works through uh blowback
without a seal without without a locked
breach it's just a game at the end of
the day we do have quite a bit of detail
of the breach and the magazine below
when the slide is open that's all good
the only other thing to say is full auto
pistols are nearly always a terrible
idea because you're going to miss with
most of your shots there are some
exceptions the Beretta 93r with its
burst mechanism yeah and anything with a
burst mechanism and a shoulder stock
well basically you've just got a small
shoulder working there firing freehand
for automatic Glock 18. there are people
who have mastered that absolutely and
they would be very effective with that
weapon most people do not do that and
then in the real world they're only ever
really used for something like a VIP
protection role where you just need lots
of bullets between you and the attacker
and then you get the hell away
yeah
thank you for watching more guns from
Apex Legends I hope you'll see us again
on this channel next week we've got our
own channel that the Royal armories on
YouTube that you might want to check out
if you haven't already back in the real
world we also have an event coming up on
the weekend of the 11th of March I'll be
there on the 11th there are tickets
available via our website if you'd like
to check that out if you can't make it
or we'd rather just keep watching the
videos we love that you do that as well
we'll see you again next time
foreign
[Music]